[Music]
BTS is back you guys with a new single
and they basically broke the damn
internet yes yes they did on Friday they
released the much-awaited music video
for boy with love check it out
[Music]
now the song features Halsey who is a
total badass
I love seeing her in this one she also
went to South Korea to work on it with
the boys okay
this music video is giving me some
serious singing in the rain vibes some
la-la-land vibes Wow BTS is known for
their dance moves I get it but still
like the boys know how to break it down
the song has to rap breaks one from
sugar and of course we know he brings it
on the keyboard and one from RM who's
given us so much swag in this all-white
suit oh come on I do another more
edition me dude up there to the West
since the release BTS related hashtags
have been the only thing that's trending
worldwide on Twitter the album math of
the soul persona is out today it has
seven songs total track for make it
right was written by Ed Sheeran and
produced by sugar fun fact
[Music]
sugar actually teased this collaboration
in December when he tweeted this pic
with the caption hmm this is for you at
ed Sheeran I'd actually shared a
screenshot of the track on Instagram on
Friday and he said that this was the
first kpop song that he'd ever worked on
and he wrote quote well done well he
picked the right people took a lab way
he did now et caught up with BTS at the
Grammys in February and they gushed over
their fandom take a look I mean they
made us they get the wings they give all
the opportunities to us so I'm sure
they'll be proud and they'll be like you
know you see all around like they're
here with us so yeah so we're so proud
do you have a message for the Army
tonight I'm yeah tell us mine they're
the Army's I love you
he gave all of this you made all of this
we're so proud and so grateful thank you
they also revealed they were hard at
work on this album even right up until
their flight to LA to the award show
we've been stayed up all night to work
for our next level right before to fly
we stayed up all night and the hard work
is just beginning for these guys they're
set to perform on Saturday Night Live
this weekend and in a promo for the show
host Emma Stone went all BTS fangirls
are camping out on this stage until BTS
get scared I don't know I can't pick a
favorite if you picked a favorite then
inevitably the others would find out and
then they would feel hurt guys guys
they can all be your favorite it's
really comforting Emma Stone is all of
us fangirling over BTS yes she is
and the show isn't actually gonna tape
until Saturday but get this court vans
are already camping outside of
Rockefeller Center in New York hoping to
score standby tickets
I'm not surprised me think it's are hot
on the market of course it will keep you
updated fully on everything there is to
know about BTS so be sure to keep it
locked to et until next time I'm
Courtney Jezebel and I'm Hallie Stevens
bye for now
you